I'd rather have a science balloons and a
science satellite with a balloon there's
no need for rockets to get a satellite
to hover over the same spot on earth
geostationary orbit you have to be
36,000 kilometers away too far to use
some sensors like radar a balloon can
fit a thousand times closer in the
stratosphere 30 to 40 kilometers above
the earth and still be above 99% of the
atmosphere with clear views of the stars
or wide panorama of Earth you can bring
down a balloon tinker with onboard
scientific equipment and then launch
again satellites not so much cost is
also a factor NOAA's for new
geostationary weather satellites are
estimated cost 11 billion dollars
whereas a balloon flight might cost just
a few hundred thousand dollars nASA has
been flying balloons for a long time but
without any steering capabilities they
drift in the wind across continents now
private industry is getting in the
balloon game with new technologies that
are enabling balloons to hover over one
spot these balloons rise and fall in the
stratosphere catching counterveiling
breezes that allow them to stay roughly
in the same place what can a balloon
with a scientific payload do it can look
down at the earth checking on storms or
animal migrations it can look out into
space peering at the surface of the Sun
or collecting cosmic rays it can even do
things in the stratosphere like studying
how ice crystals could reflect sunlight
and cool the planet how do you keep a
balloon stable enough to use a telescope
gyroscopes can help keep a platform
pointed at its target even as it sits in
a twisting gondola but this isn't an ADD
for scientific balloons there are a few
caveats for example while satellites
last for years the longest balloon
flights have been a few months and what
goes up needs to come down
so most balloons come with Perry
I can bring their payloads down gently
[Music]